the way it works usually is uh when the
sort of mechanics of how it works is
they have a story meeting with the
executive producers and they say okay
well let's have tubing on the FLDS and
then a Booker will call me and we'll
just to arrange logistics and then I'll
talk to a producer who that producer and
I will go back and forth about what's
important to talk about you know we'll
talk about the substance and then
shortly before the show I will often
talk to campbell or Anderson about how
we want to do something so that's the
mechanics of how it works because the
you know a lot of television is sort of
the moving the the logistical beast you
know in sort of getting the people to
the right time time and place and if
you're it's easy to let that take over
everything else and I always try to make
sure that I have substantive
conversations with the people involved
about what we're actually talking about
in the news not just you know what set
are you going to use where you're going
to go get a makeup and all that stuff
which which tends to take up a lot of
time
you